foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Tuesday morning
[Music]
a lot of news out of New York
looks like there was a shooting
in a subway car
Brooklyn Sunset Park
apparently someone has entered the car
set off some sort of smoke bomb it
appears and starts firing a weapon
starts firing a gun and some are saying
a handgun and it's very unclear at this
point it seems like and I've got a video
to show here I'm here in just a bit when
we start to go through some of the news
and the Tweety tweets and attorney
Trends uh it appears that they did it on
a moving car
and uh because there is a video that I
have seen on the internet and retweeted
people coming out of the sub the Smoky
subway car
um some people appear to be injured uh
in that in that footage so when we play
it no
we do not look away here and um
there are what appears to be some people
injured now it's unclear how they're
injured but you're only assuming that
it's possible gunshot wounds
um so
if you're squeamish
then you might want to it's it's really
not that bad I've looked through the
video
I made sure that there wasn't anything
gruesome in the video before we show it
but it does show people injured again
it's very unclear how they're injured
you're only assuming that they're
injured through gunshot wounds so we'll
show that
um
it's uh very unfortunate that we have to
continue to do this in this country
where we have to talk about people going
into public areas and firing weapons and
innocent civilians uh whether it's
because of mental illness or terrorism
or whatever whatever thing you want to
[ __ ] blame
why someone shot other human beings with
a firearm
um outside any kind of Justified Force
you really you really it goes back to
the actual possession of the firearm it
really does and you know we're gonna do
this whole stupid [ __ ] thing
over the next few days of good guy bad
guy uh if there would have been someone
with a gun they could have stopped this
guy with a gun because that's the
solution when someone gets on a railroad
car or a subway car and starts firing a
weapon there's more people to fire a
weapon into the crowd right in a smoky
crowd
um it appears that that's what the
distraction was
um also there was talk that there was
other maybe uh different devices in the
subway uh the NYPD
put out a report I retweeted it that
that they have not seen any more
uh any more devices in the subway so and
we'll go through some of that this is
the big news today the Sunset Park uh
shooting
um when uh and we're going to uh so
we're going to go through that we're
also going to go through some more news
in New York the lieutenant governor of
the state of New York has been arrested
on what appears to be bribe Federal
bribery charges so we're going to go
through we're going to go through that
as well
um but we will we will go through those
two big Stories the other big story is
uh the media sucks at reporting about
what inflation is and what inflation
isn't they [ __ ] suck
um that's the title of today's episode
116 is that the media is wrong on
inflation they're just [ __ ] wrong
don't listen to the [ __ ] media don't
especially when it comes to inflation
they're not reporting on it correctly
trust me on this they're not
if you want to know why and how in a
real quick real quick snippet would you
rather be in a [ __ ] recession
we went through a bigger recession in
2008. right before Barack Obama became
president
and it took years to drag us out of that
recession years to drag us out of that
recession
part of the problem with inflation right
now is a heated economy
we have we have we have below four
percent unemployment which is virtually
almost no unemployment when you get down
below three percent you're pretty much
fully employed in the country there is
high demand folks I don't know if you've
been out there but everyone's like oh
there's a labor shortage no there's not
a labor shortage
there's a wage shortage in some places
for sure and you can spot the places
that there's wage shortages
just go they got all the places that
have the Help Wanted signs and they
[ __ ] about they can't hire anybody and
they can't keep anybody that's because
they aren't paying them what they're
worth
it's not [ __ ] complicated it really
isn't
it it really is not complicated to
understand how the economy operates
it's pretty [ __ ] simple in fact and
so we're gonna go through that today too
so we're gonna cover
guns the economy
and we're gonna get to God I guess
because Jesus Christ Our Lord is
trending oh [ __ ] what is this [ __ ] I
don't I don't even know why just seen it
trending in the top 30. I put it in the
list because I'm sure it's some [ __ ]
stupid ass [ __ ]
I'm sure I'm sure when you see stuff
like this trending so we're gonna do
God's guns in the economy so we're gonna
go through the whole [ __ ] gamut today
of messaging
uh but again back to the shooting at
Sunset Park uh
here's what's going to happen because
Maga is already out there talking about
how you know there's the
Eric Adams the black mayor and somehow
that has something to do with this
because the suspect I guess is a black
man so this has something to do with him
being mayor net you know they're going
to continue with their [ __ ] racism
and their [ __ ] bigotry
you know it can't it can't be it can't
be
that people who shouldn't have [ __ ]
guns have access to guns nah it can't be
that can't be that more guns is the
answer more guns because you know having
four or five more people on the subway
car firing weapons at each other would
have been much [ __ ] better whoa God
that would have been just [ __ ]
fantastic wouldn't it that would have
really stopped all those all those bad
guys with those guns
it really is [ __ ] bone-headed and
this event is going to prove that the
idea that more guns is good
more guns not good it's not
Jesus guns God and the economy and
that's what we're gonna do today
it's it's noon Eastern 11 Central nine
Pacific and you know what time that is
it's time for the Tony Michaels podcast
right here on YouTube Twitter twitch all
our new listeners out here listening on
the Facebook uh Midas Touch page are the
mind is touch Facebook page either way
you look at it we're on the books of
face folks and we have a ton new
listeners listening so if you are a new
listener out there
every single weekday Monday through
Friday YouTube Twitter twitch go follow
us on YouTube in case you miss us
you can always go over there and
re-watch the episode
you can go re-watch the episode on
YouTube Twitter twitch or on the Midas
touch Facebook page you can watch it but
it's really easy to go subscribe set the
Bell notification
you can get in on the Super Chat on
YouTube the Super Chat
Super Chat
if you want to support the show
financially that would be fantastic you
can buy a super sticker people like to
get in the chat and talk to each other
and talk to me again I come up with a
little system if you guys are talking to
me or want me to you know see your
comment try to put a star a couple stars
in front of it you know the Emoji
so I can notice it because sometimes you
guys are talking to each other and I'm
not exactly in on the conversation
necessarily you know I'm running I'm
running the show here it's not like
there's 500 producers you know sitting
in a room somewhere else it's me
it's just me and then sometimes it's
Gabe sometimes it's Gabe which I think
Gabe Sanchez is going to join us today
thank goodness we're gonna have Gabe
Sanchez everyone loves Gabe
everyone loves them some dirty Sanchez
I don't know if you know what a dirty
Sanchez is but maybe we'll nickname him
then he's not on the show right now so
maybe we'll maybe we'll give him that
nickname
I don't know if you know what that is go
look it up not right now don't go Google
it don't leave the show God damn it go
look it up later make a mental note
dirty Sanchez and if you Google it you
know be careful but you know maybe we'll
give Gabe that nickname hello to
everyone out there
Debbie from Salt Lake Andrea Midas Robin
Jay is here Nancy's here Lyndon from
Facebook MJ good morning MJ she says
hello [ __ ] em fam yesterday was MJ's
birthday we wished her a happy birthday
she couldn't join us so everyone wish
her a happy late birthday since she's
here today in the chat don't forget to
uh give some shout outs to MJ uh Liz is
here Amanda's here Don from Facebook's
here Jamie's here Vinnie's here
who else is here Yoda's here uh I don't
we're getting so many people in the chat
it's hard to name everybody
but um stay with us here on the Tony
Michaels podcast again every single
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
we bring you the hard-hitting news the
treaty tweets the trendy Trends and we
try to get you to laugh we try to get
you to get pissed off
um yesterday I went off uh someone
someone from Facebook said I should calm
down calm down Tony calm the [ __ ] down
well guess what guess what the Oklahoma
governor is going to make it a felony
for a woman who is pregnant to have a
medical procedure oh man oh maybe I
should calm the [ __ ] down huh maybe I
should just calm down and just relax and
not worry about other people's Liberty
being [ __ ] stripped away from them in
this country where we have a
constitution maybe I should just calm
the [ __ ] down we got someone in the
subway in New York firing a [ __ ]
weapon at a [ __ ] innocent civilians
oh maybe I should just calm the [ __ ]
down maybe I should just calm the [ __ ]
down
nope not gonna happen not I'm not gonna
do it
not gonna do it
we're gonna also watch some some footage
from Tennessee where again they're
attacking trans children they're [ __ ]
sexualizing gender in Tennessee of your
children they're coming after you
they're coming after your children
they're going to do it that's where
they're going with this folks that's
what fascism does when they start to get
a little bit of [ __ ] Taste of taking
your Liberty away and really banging up
people that they [ __ ] hate and they
[ __ ] don't like and they don't want
them to exist and they get a little
taste of that boy they really [ __ ] go
all in
and you think they're not going to do
that that's what they're going to run on
that's what they're going to run on
they're going to run on sexualizing kids
gender I'm telling you're going to run
on marrying children folks that's what
they're going to run on you know how
we're going to make them do that we're
gonna make them do that we're gonna
[ __ ] make them have to talk about how
they're obsessed obsessed with your
children's gender obsessed with your
children's genitalia they're [ __ ]
obsessed with people's genitalian
bathrooms they're obsessed with
sexualizing everything they're [ __ ]
obsessed with who someone else loves
they're [ __ ] obsessed with the
woman's [ __ ] uterus they're [ __ ]
obsessed with your body they're obsessed
with their children and they don't want
you to have any of it and by the way by
the way they're gonna take your [ __ ]
consent away
for them to marry your children speaking
of your children don't doubt me I'm
telling you that's the next [ __ ] step
why why wouldn't they take away your
consent to marry your children I mean
that's uh that's the natural Next Step
I mean Jesus Christ are already passing
bills in Missouri Tennessee Florida's
Nets Texas is by God they're gonna out
Florida for [ __ ] sure on this
marrying kids thing
and the next step is to take away your
consent
to marry their doubt me doubt look what
happened in Oklahoma look what happened
they're making it a felony to for
consent for a medical procedure
to save someone's [ __ ] life
to have autonomy and Liberty over their
goddamn body their own [ __ ]
body my body my choice where are those
[ __ ] huh where are the
anti-masters that held the my body my
choice signs up out in front of a
[ __ ] Burger King because they
couldn't buy a Whopper because they make
bad [ __ ] stupid decisions
where the [ __ ] are they are they driving
down the Oklahoma right now no no
they're not
they're not going to
they're not because they're [ __ ]
Hypocrites they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about
they have no idea they bought into this
fascism Hook Line Sinker it's the same
[ __ ] where they're calling Disney
groomers while in Tennessee they're
trying to groom children to marry them
to [ __ ] them they old men want to [ __ ]
little girls
that's what they want to do you've
you've everyone's good oh my God that's
that's incendiary language what else
what else would a 30 40 50 year old man
want to marry a 12 year old girl a 10
year old girl for huh huh
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
we know what you sick [ __ ]
Republican pedocons wanna do you [ __ ]
kid diddlers
don't doubt me don't doubt me they're
coming for your consent for your
children they're coming for it they're
already doing it with these trans bills
they're making it [ __ ] criminal in
Texas for a kid to receive treatment
even just counseling
because they question their gender and
their gender identity
because parents seek counseling for that
child nope you're a criminal they're
coming for the consent of your children
they're coming for it folks
and your children are on their list
because you're a libtard and you're
teaching them how to be gay
we want we don't want people to be gay
we want her to be straight that way all
those boys can grow up to marry little
girls and all those little girls can
marry grown men
tell me I'm [ __ ] wrong
Republicans are a bunch of [ __ ]
pedicon kid diddlers that's what they
are
and anyone who stands with these
[ __ ] anyone who votes for
anyone who has an R next to their name I
don't give a [ __ ] who it is city council
County Commission [ __ ] dog catcher
if if they stand with an R next to their
name then they stand with those [ __ ]
sickos in Tennessee the sickos who are
trying to pass a child bride bill here
in Missouri all under the guise of
hating gay people by the way oh they
[ __ ] they [ __ ] hate LGBT community
people they want to [ __ ] ostracize
them from the society they shouldn't
have any rights any Liberty whatsoever
and they're coming for their Liberty too
you doubt me they're gonna they're
coming for women they're gonna come for
the LGBT community next
it's gonna happen
and these marriage laws that where grown
men are trying to marry little girls
they're using up the hate the hate gay
attitude
let's let's hate on some gays with some
legislation because you know Republicans
couldn't pass any [ __ ] legislation
without discriminating against someone
for sure not a [ __ ] piece of
legislation could they pass that doesn't
have someone that they're discriminating
against I mean think about this think
about the meeting that they're having oh
okay okay okay Chuck
so who are we discriminating against in
this bill well Harold we're not
discriminating against anybody ah we're
not doing this bill [ __ ] that bill that
bill sucks it doesn't discriminate
against anybody we need discrimination
and every [ __ ] Bill we're
Republicans for crying out loud don't
you know who we are
go look at their slate of legislation go
look at it voting rights discrimination
marriage laws marriage laws
discrimination
medical laws abortion laws
discrimination
go go look at it
go
go read the I mean everyone wants to all
the Democrats and liberals out there
they always want to huff and puff about
[ __ ] line items and bills and how
it's so important that we run on bills
and we got to have our bills we got to
know oh God we got to know exactly how
much an hour this person's gonna gonna
pay us we got to know where they stand
on health care we got to know we got to
know if they're for canceling student
debt shut the [ __ ] up
you ain't gonna have no [ __ ] student
debt and neither are your kids
especially your daughters they ain't
gonna have no [ __ ] student debt you
think these [ __ ] are gonna let
your daughters go to college
you think these fascists that want to
marry your little girls are gonna let
them go to college that's what you think
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
to forget about canceling student debt
these [ __ ] don't even want you
to have student debt they don't want you
to go get educated are you kidding me
there ain't gonna be no such thing as
student debt ain't gonna be no such
thing as [ __ ] University or college
not in this country
why would there be
why why would there be
they don't need they don't need college
and universities if they start marrying
off little girls at 12 years old
what the [ __ ] do they need to go to
college for they're being groomed to be
wives and and bird mayors
to be in Mommy Mode you remember that
[ __ ] video
doubt me doubt me go go go out there and
you [ __ ] just talk about canceling
student debt see how far it gets you in
this election
see how far it [ __ ] gets you
yeah great I I'm for canceling student
debt I'm not against it
I'm not [ __ ] against it I'm for it
[ __ ] yeah we should cancel all of it
sure let's do that but guess what guess
what you're gonna let a [ __ ] bunch of
pedophile Republican pedocon kid dealers
you're gonna let them in charge because
you can't shut the [ __ ] up about
canceling student debt to win one
goddamn election huh
you can't get your [ __ ] head out of
your ass long enough to [ __ ] put a
message together
so that way you can fight this [ __ ]
on inflation and gas prices
you're gonna let them take over the
country because you can't figure out how
to talk to someone about a [ __ ] issue
they want to make this election
about Disney and liberals
grooming children
remember remember the last election we
had not not 2020.
I'm talking about last year in Virginia
remember that election
in Virginia in the governor's race when
they put us on defense I mean the
Democrats
when they put us on defense
about education and Glenn Younkin now is
terrorizing
the state of Virginia terrorizing them
with these [ __ ] shitty policies the
exact opposite of what he said he was
going to do
well do you want to do that again
because if you don't want to do that
again pluck your head out of your ass
and realize that we have to win this
election
not just in the house but in the Senate
we have to [ __ ] win this thing we
don't have a choice if you if you want
if you want it to where women who get
medical procedures or [ __ ] felons if
you want to make it to where they're
sexualizing your kids gender if you want
to make it if you want to make it to
where they can marry your daughters well
then fine fine go have really shitty
messaging and talk to the fewest amount
of people that you can possibly talk to
about an issue that that [ __ ] rings
to them
they want to die on the hill that
they're wanting to marry little girls
you got it
they're gonna die on that Hill because
they're fascist
they're gonna go die on the hill that
women should be felons if they get a
medical procedure to save their lives
doubt me
that's the hill they're gonna go die on
that's the political Hill that they want
to fight on you don't think we can win
that [ __ ] fight you don't think
Democrats and people who are
pro-democracy can win the fight of
fascists taking away women's Liberty of
even making their own [ __ ] medical
decisions about their bodies you think
we can't win the fight of them
sexualizing our kids gender obsessed
with their genitalia [ __ ] obsessed
with children's genitalia not only that
trying to marry children
you don't think we can win that fight
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
that is the fight we want that is the
fight we should have that's where that's
what they want that's what they're doing
that's the only thing they can do is
pass policies to [ __ ] hate people
hatred bigotry homophobia transphobia
pedophilia that's all they got that's
all they can focus on they can't get
anywhere else but there
and you think we can't win that fight
get the [ __ ] out of here we can win that
fight all day long
all day long we can win that fight but
we have to fight that fight
we have to fight that fight we got to go
at him right there right at that if
you're if you're gonna box someone you
don't go to a different ring to box them
you get in the ring and you box them and
you beat the holy piss out of them so
let's politically beat the holy piss out
of them let's do it what are we waiting
on
it's like this Subway shooting they're
gonna [ __ ] make this whole goddamn
thing
and they're gonna [ __ ] with us and it's
gonna fight I'm telling you Liberals are
gonna have so many bad takes on this
so many bad takes so many bad takes and
the only good take is this the answer is
to have more guns in that [ __ ] that
smoked up Subway car that's the good
idea that you have Brainiac is to make
sure more people were firing guns
because good guy with a gun stops a bad
guy with a gun well if New York didn't
have such shitty gun laws if everyone
could could see you and carry
oh they could have just went pee poo poo
poo and Shot 14 other more people [ __ ]
them
that's what that's what they're gonna
say they're gonna say mental illness
this guy's mentally he was a terrorist
God knows what his name is if it's if if
his name's any kind of funny name oh
look at here look he's a liberal and
he's a oh he's a black man and scary
black dude shoots you when there's no
gun loan there's a intense gun laws
that's the [ __ ] they're gonna say we
could win that fight too
you don't have to be [ __ ] scared of
these political fights
another example a good story today out
of New York is a lieutenant governor is
arrested and indicted on federal charges
for bribery
oh see they're gonna say see see the
Democrats Democrats they're the ones
they get indicted well if you're so
[ __ ] hung up [ __ ] on the
Department of Justice and they're so
unfair then why isn't it unfair that the
Democratic lieutenant governor was
indicted actually my guess is my guess
is and here's what I'm going to say is
if they can indict that [ __ ]
they can have died a whole lot of other
[ __ ] that are in politics how
about that
the feds are coming for you
[ __ ] who are in politics
they're not scared they're not scared to
even prosecute someone who's currently
holding an office
good luck
yep
messaging messaging go Adam we have to
fight this fight not not next week not
next month not the month before the
midterm right now right now we have to
fight this fight it is so important I
have another announcement and I'm not
sure what time but I think we're gonna
have Rachel bittickoff or Dr Rachel
bittickoffer the political strategist
joining us today now I'm not sure
exactly what subject she wants to talk
about but I'm sure she gets him good
when she wants to talk about she
messaged me this morning say hey I'm
gonna come on the show I said great I'll
send you the link so I'm not sure
exactly what time she's going to be here
but Dr Rachel bittickoffer one of your
favorites is gonna be here sometime
today
and I think Gabe uh Sanchez is going to
join us as well so let's do this let's
go to a quick break and we'll be right
back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out daddy light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us through the
break
[Music]
Hellboy
we get so much stuff going on today well
the number one the
the
story out of Sunset Park in Brooklyn uh
where there was a Subway shooting on a
subway car apparently a man walked into
a subway car with some smoke bombs
um injured a bunch of people I don't I'm
not sure of the if there's a fatality
count or the injury count it it is in
the dozens I believe
that were injured in the subway guard
appears that the smoke bomb was the
distraction and it was
um
oh
it was the
likely a semi-automatic
um handgun it seems like in close range
that was used to Fire and injure these
people on this subway car so let's do
this we got tons of stories to get to
let's go to the Tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
like we do every day let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the Tony
Michaels podcast we have reached this
segment of the shitless Roundup where we
round up all the Tweety tweets and the
trendy Trends
um a lot of people are saying Zero
fatalities it seems like there um is
only injuries so that's good if that is
the news uh thank you MJ for that so
hopefully um there is no uh
life-threatening injuries
um I'm gonna show you a video here and
here real soon on the timeline of what
it kind of looked like down in the
subway car when they um were coming out
of the subway car so let's let's uh
let's do this let's go to the timeline
and see if we can find that video real
quick of Sunset Park
um it is that is good news that there's
no fatalities
um you know apparently this person had a
gas mask on is what they're saying
um you know I I don't know of any
confirmation of this or video footage of
this but uh they were saying the Indiana
gas man it's gone I guess uh which would
indicate you know that there was
premeditation with the get with the
smoke bomb or whatever it was
um that he set off now
um I I don't know like a gas mask uh
keeps you from inhaling the gas but it
doesn't make you see through it so
hopefully him setting off the smoke bomb
or whatever thing he set off was
actually caused him to wear
um he didn't fatally kill someone and
what I'm saying by that is you know if
you were set off a smoke dot bomb to
make sure no one saw where the shooting
was coming from you possibly wouldn't be
able to see where you were shooting at
if that makes sense
a mask you know isn't going to make you
see through the smoke it just makes it
to where you can't inhale it
um so sending off a smoke bomb the fire
into a crowd May
and you know he was probably trying to
kill more people but it may have made it
um where it actually only where injuries
non-fatal injuries so hopefully there
are no fatalities uh David Macker let me
make this a little bigger uh posted this
video and he's kind of got a thread
going here on this event
um we're doing some reporting he said
video shows Panic commuters fleeing from
subway
car full of smoke so I'm going to show
this video here again
if you are if you are a little squeamish
you definitely should uh
you definitely should possibly look away
but this is uh this is uh subway car
um where they're getting out of the
smoke cover car we have Gabe with us uh
oh oh he's saying he's saying no he's
not ready yet so uh I will I will wait
for him to be ready let's watch this
video and then maybe maybe our executive
producer can figure out his microphone
[Music]
you see here this person is actually in
the subway car and when they step out
they're in the subway car ahead of the
one where the smoke is you see them
coming out with the smoke
um people are running uh afraid and it's
very hard you know because there is such
chaos here
at the sea if there's any one of the the
same one of course you see someone
limping here you're only making the
assumption that maybe that person was
shot because
um you know it's it looks like they're
shining a leg and then there's another
person hobbling here so
these are apparently some of the
injuries from the gunshot wounds
um
I've warned you
[Music]
um
but we don't look away here we we watch
what we want to watch we cannot look
away because guys this is this is your
future with the Republicans
this is what they want you're looking at
right now what they want in this country
is they want guns everywhere they
probably wanted more guns on this on
this subway car that way more people
could fire more ammunition at each other
yeah why not hell why not if you're
gonna sling bullets around let's really
sling them around let's do that it
really is [ __ ] dumb
that we can't manage to make sure that
weapons do not get in the hands of
people who are going on subway cars and
shooting innocent people through a smoke
bomb
this really is this really is [ __ ]
dumb that we can't handle this we can
handle this in this country we can do
this and I think we have Gabe uh now is
uh able to join us Gabe how are you this
morning I'm good thank you yeah did you
see the video I just showed I yeah I I
saw that earlier today yeah but I've
been coming out of the subway car I I
I'm I'm guessing that the Republicans
answer to this is going to be well there
should have been four or five more guns
firing in that subway car to you know
shoot the guy who had you know good guy
bad guy [ __ ] right yeah it's it will I I
will anticipate somebody saying the only
way or you know the whole party's saying
the only way to
to uh to prevent that problem is right
you only is by introducing more more
ammunition more Yeah well yeah well I
mean I mean the only way to solve a
problem is to you know compound the
problem that's a good way to solve it
right yeah it's like how do we uh how do
we put out the fire well we throw on
some gasoline Yeah well yeah why
wouldn't you I mean you know you really
want to stoke it up so um it sounds like
there's only injuries which is a good
thing I mean
having that there's no fatalities is a
good thing that we're not having
anything in this event I don't think
there's any fatal injuries are you
talking about in the subway car itself
because I believe I believe so have they
caught this guy yet not that I know of
when I saw online I saw the video the
subway car I saw that there was you know
the guy's uh dressed up in
um
in like uh
uh like a like a neon vest kind of like
he looks like a worker it looks like it
doesn't sound yeah it's like a
construction vest and he had like a gas
mask because it was obvious that it was
premeditated too so right smoke bomb
which I actually may have saved these
people's lives that he set off the smoke
bomb because a gas mask doesn't make you
see through the smoke it makes you not
inhale the smoke so so it would impair
his vision almost as much or more than
it would impair someone else's so it
would be very difficult to fire into a
crowd and if you couldn't spray him if
that was your goal
um it looks like uh David Mackey or he's
been reporting on this this morning
where I retweeted that video because he
retweeted uh the NYPD actually tweeted
out that um the subway station in
Brooklyn there are no active explosive
devices at this time
um because the word was this morning
that there were some more devices but I
think it's whatever the smoke bomb that
he was setting off right you know the
other thing that I just thought of this
is going to be used as an example of why
like
it's going to be used against the Deep
like defund the police uh movement
oh yeah oh yeah they're gonna Grudge out
all the troops right right which is you
know which is unfortunate because
obviously like you're you know you're
using the fatality of other toward
others for your goal to push
uh empowering they want to know how to
fight that you wanna know how to fight
that when someone says that [ __ ] like oh
yeah it's the defund the police is the
reason why this happened well Democrats
are the only ones uh actually funding
getting Government funding actual
taxpayer dollars to pay police so you
know it's kind of it's kind of it's kind
of ironic that you're blaming on
debunding police when you're doing that
so you know I think that's the uh the
thing also just a complete
misunderstanding of what defund the
police is like they're you know they
don't want to listen I agree I will go
out and say defund the police I don't
think is the best marketing tagline sure
absolutely for what it actually is but I
do anticipate uh Republicans to really
push forward this idea that oh this is
why it happened or t fund the police
will never happen like you know this is
why uh or you know someone's gonna say
oh if we don't defund the police well
we're gonna send some sort of uh uh like
psych eval in like you know that's the I
guarantee someone like Don Jr is going
to make some [ __ ] dumb joke about how
what we should have done if we defunded
the police was sending someone to like
assess a domestic violence situation
like are we going to send in the same
person who's a specialist in that field
to go deal with a shooting and it's like
no you dumb [ __ ] like that's not what
we're talking about right so Dave macier
is um reported an hour ago FDNY tells me
eight people were shot yeah I think that
number has been updated since yeah well
and he's got down here 20 minutes ago
FDNY tells media 16 injured 10 with
gunshot wounds find critical but stable
yeah
um so it seems like they're not
life-threatening injuries at this point
and I would imagine that the 16 injuries
are probably people trying to get off
that car right or trying to get away
from this game you know I you know I
don't know I'm not sure if there's some
sort of like
um
reason for it or not you know I don't
know what the guy's situation is in
terms of like if you know right clearly
you know is it one of those situations
like the Aurora theater shooting you
know that happened or like is it that
type of person like
why I mean it's obviously a person that
should not have access to Firearms right
no totally you know and and here here's
the other Trope that they're gonna do
and the other [ __ ] that the right wing
is gonna uh trudge out and this is what
liberals usually they're like oh you
can't talk about that because they're
gonna they're gonna attack us on it [ __ ]
that let them attack us we got better
attacks than they do right suspect is a
heavy set black man apparently he's five
five
um he's about the 170 180 pounds I think
is what they were saying this morning
he's wearing a green construction vest
now when I think construction invest I
think orange but it's a green one so and
it also he's got a gray hooded
sweatshirt on so right
um if you if you are in the New York
Brooklyn area and you do see someone uh
with this description you probably
should contact authorities not approach
the person right um you know not that
that person would be that person but you
definitely should be very cautious if
you see someone
um out there with a green hood or a
green construction
yeah I don't know if that's like a green
green or if that's like a neon yeah yeah
well it's probably a neon green because
it's probably like a um because green
normally is more like a road
construction right they're doing road
construction a lot of times like um to
catch attention or something right green
orange but I I was thinking orange this
morning when they were saying right a
construction vest but apparently he had
a gas mask as well
um but I would imagine uh this person
who had premeditated the smoke bombs and
for whatever reason you know again
they're going to do the whole oh it's
not the gun it's mental illness it's
it's not the gun it's the defund the
police it's not the gun black people are
violent I mean they're going to trudge
out every [ __ ] which is so which is
you know is incredibly infuriating
because you look at then you say oh it's
not the gun okay five it's not the gun
you want to admit that there's mental
health issues in this country then let's
right let's find out let's fix that
let's let's put funds no no they don't
want to the gate gate they don't want to
fix the problem they just want to tell
us what the problem is right I mean I
mean I'm not saying there's not a mental
health problem in this country have you
seen some of this queuing on [ __ ] that
we got there is definitely an argument
to be made for mental health care in
this country like they stop but also
probably not letting anyone who
shouldn't have a firearm have one is
probably Another good argument you know
I mean another argument would say if
there was no gun then there would be no
shooting no I'm you know hey look I'm no
rocket scientist but if I were to do the
math on this I would say shooting is
from bullets of gun and if there is no
Bulls from gun then there is no shooting
wait you mean you mean what you're
saying is you can't just take A Fistful
of bullets and throw them at someone I
mean unless you're like a superhero well
I mean you know well they do the
mediocre white man might think he is a
superhero and then you know what I I
feel like you know uh like from The Mask
uh where he like oh yeah and he spits
him back out yeah he spits him back out
so you know maybe something they watch
that movie so it must be true Gabe I
mean like it's a movie it's in a movie
they saw it on on the Internet it's true
it's got to be it's in a [ __ ] movie I
mean they believe anything else in a
[ __ ] movie I mean it's it's
ridiculous this is um this is getting
this Hunter Biden laptop thing
um you know we still see yeah but still
yeah uh always there's a I have a I have
a done I have well here's the thing I've
got like
maybe three but definitely two I got a
Don Junior video that's coming out
that's him trying to sell the our
journey together book okay so it's kind
of what what is this what is this
our journey together is the book now
this is what really pisses me off so
it's a book that Trump released that's a
it's a photo book right it's a it's a
bunch of photos wait wait is it like a
picture coloring book or an actual
picture that's what I thought at first
and I thought was totally fitting but
here's the thing I mean it's the only
book that you'll probably find in the
like it when when Trump builds his
little bathroom Library what's gonna end
up happening is you're gonna find this
our journey together uh you're gonna
like uh
the two John Junior books and art of
making the deal those are gonna be the
only books that you find in there well
come on now I I mean I I envisioned
there's an endless supply because they
didn't sell the books actually right
right well I Envision I Envision uh
Donald Trump's bathroom Library like the
vanity like there's some oh he took it
down from the wall but there's so many
like cable well there's so many like
like old 1990s porno mags like oh yeah
pouring out of it and all the pages are
riffed and stuck together and like
they're laying on the floor and you know
every once in a while the the maid comes
back in and stuffs them back in the
vanity and closes the door but they
can't keep so so this our journey
together is a is a photo book a
collection of moments throughout his
presidency and it's like photos of him
doing stuff but also photos of
uh Donald Trump's like notes that he
writes it's just like on a desk you know
and just like take it it's wait wait
wait so it's like like uh you wrote a
note to just to your loved one and said
hey headed out for a little bit be back
in 20 minutes yeah yeah but it's on
White House like letterhead you know of
course and it just says like hey uh I
don't love my son right now sorry Don Jr
I don't know who Eric is love love yeah
you're like a new phone new burner who
it is
but the way that this ended up happening
was so he releases this book in the
beginning of December right and there I
just saw a video with him and Kimberly
uh Guilfoyle uh don don Jr and Kimberly
Guilfoyle they were they were promoting
this book to be they're trying to pimp
it right right
and which is funny because they're like
doing this live and there's like [ __ ]
happened in the background so they're
like kind of half distracted half
focusing on this live but anyway the
thing that really pissed me off was that
the
um
the uh the photographer the chief White
House photographer I think her name is
uh Sheila Craighead and
she was going to she was going to
release this book you know like all all
photographers of the president's like
that work for presidents typically do
they're like hey here's a here's a
collection of events that happened while
he was president or or whatever
um I want to share what I experienced so
they'll release a book right it's not
it's not uncommon they do this they
might ask the president that that they
were working with to like you know do
like a little forward or whatever here's
where Trump decides to do things
differently he says oh you know what
actually I'm gonna get the lawyers and
them to to stop you we're going to stop
you from releasing this book right now
um doesn't say why so she's like okay
well [ __ ] I I can't okay okay I can't
release it then it turns out that the
reason he did that was so that he could
then take the photos and then release
the book so he stole her photos
and drop the book and that's what he did
and so that there were actually a New
York Times article that came out so wait
a second this our journey is lifted from
someone else so I don't know if that's
the original title for her book but her
book was going to have a bunch of these
photos then he said uh wait wait wait
don't release the photos yet don't
release the book don't publish it I just
want to look through this
then he took the photos and then
released his own book called our journey
together so do you think he lifted the
photos didn't pay her and then tried to
profit on it do you think
and I'm just do you think he said it on
the desk and he's like got his cell
phone and he's taking the pictures and
that's how well
I wish I mean it would be here
I need the I need the I need the
manuscript background I need like the
sample back he's like oh hold on hold on
yeah he's still taking pictures or or
maybe he's got like an old ass scanner
you know and he's oh yeah
he's scanning it or he's got he's got
like he's got Eric scanning it because
you know Eric Eric likes to hold the
makeup for his wife yeah but he's
probably scanning the pages of this book
so that way they can release it oh my
God
so you have a video coming out about
this book it sounds so I have a video
yes and it's an update huh it's yeah
it's not it's just like it's it's Don Jr
trying to sell this book so you could
you can think of it kind of like a
commercial you know but it just can be
down junior pleading to get people to
buy the book the other one I'm gonna do
is obviously around where is Junior
everyone's been asking everyone wants to
know where's Don Jr where is Junior
right for the same reason people that
worse Hunter bud and where's his laptop
well you know what you want to do you
know what you could do you could have
Mark Meadows text him and I'm sure he
would be able to find I'm just saying oh
yeah I mean you know what I bet they
probably have like fine my friends or
something well it's possible or either
that or that their Signal app they
probably go on their signal however
speaking of Mark Meadows I do have and
Donald Trump Jr I do have a third
edition okay of the uh dramatic reading
of text messages sent to Mark Meadows
from this person and this version is
text messages sent to Mark Meadows from
Donald Trump Jr so you know there's some
nuggets in there be looking out for
these uh Gabe Sanchez uh videos out
there you know uh before you came on the
air I think I gave you a nickname
everyone seemed to like it
um and I don't know I told him not to go
Google this right away because I don't
want them to leave the show but dirty
sanchez is
I mean I I don't know maybe maybe we
give Gabe a nickname I I will say this
uh I do no I it's a funny name oh yeah
do not do not what's that on your uh
that's a that's an actual okay it's an
actual moment if anyone that doesn't
know wait until after the show and then
you can go yeah and beware though maybe
do it like Incognito if you're gonna
right right yeah yeah yeah if you're at
a work computer go to the bathroom
definitely don't Google Images it just
yeah you don't yeah don't you don't want
Google Images here's the thing I have to
say
people who are younger you know
do they know what it does I I mean you
know I I'm not I don't know I don't know
right I mean who know I didn't know this
morning I was gonna start talking about
dirty sanchez but this is what the
conversation went you know well when you
get when you come on the show you never
know what the hell we're gonna talk
about yeah speaking of that speaking of
that you never know what the hell is
going to happen this morning uh
lieutenant governor of New York speaking
of uh unexpected stories uh Benjamin
Brian Benjamin excuse me indicted in
campaign donation scheme uh the AP has
it here he was arrested this morning in
the donation scheme apparently at uh
they're calling it bribery and it's a
federal charge now this is also going to
be used against the right wing like see
it's the Democrats it's the Democrats
that do all this and you know that's
going to be their narrative
um and how you fight back against that
is say oh so they do charge an arrest
politicians who are sitting politicians
do that
um you know hey bring the same energy
that's all I mean that's really what you
got to say for the same people who are
like you know know I I retweeted a a
tweet with a thing that said I was about
Jared Kushner taking a two billion
dollar investment right from Saudi
Arabia and obviously there's a lot of
shady stuff in terms of how that deal
was handled and the money that was a
little bit yeah yeah yeah just just did
you just me and she was just a smidge
um but uh you know I think my original
tweet said something like oh or like no
please tell me how Hunter Biden's laptop
is the problem and not Jared Kushner
getting two billion dollars I'll wait
the responses I got were
were insane the people that were like oh
this guy's an idiot referring to me also
saying um you're you're an idiot I'm an
idiot they're like oh and the people
like well two things can be true and
it's like I'm not saying that listen
I'll be the first one to say right now
if there is a legitimate reason to
investigate Hunter Biden or there's a
problem then [ __ ] them right yeah like
if there's wrongdoing then do it I'm not
defending Hunter Biden but what I am
saying is that if you're gonna come with
the same energy to say that a
politician's son benefited financially
and politically through the office held
by their father then they should be
investigated and the same goes for uh
you know Donald Trump Jr and the same
goes for Jared Kushner if there's
someone there that's benefiting
illegally uh through financial means or
political means because of their father
or their stepfather in the office that
they held then please but the people
that were in there are are I mean like
you know people agreed with it obviously
because it is like oh well let's [ __ ]
call this out some people are like well
I don't like Hunter but this is really
shady and I'm like okay well okay we can
I can agree with that sure great look
into it other people are like oh he's
just business savvy like oh yeah yeah
yeah or someone goes so when Hunter
Biden takes foreign money that's the
elite right but when they do it it's or
or someone says they're like Jared
Kushner really worked for this or Jared
Kushner taking 2 billion didn't actually
go to him but it went to his investment
for it's like okay do you not do do you
not think that there is a a very small
barrier between Jared Kushner and Jared
kushner's fund like you don't tell me
that this guy has direct access to like
pull funds and replace funds and do this
and do that like full [ __ ] [ __ ] the
investment was to Jared Kushner right
for whatever things that are tied
together in terms of allegations about
murder or not right well the best part
is is that it's it's it's crown bone saw
that [ __ ] gave him this money I mean
it's not like it was some kind of
investment firm I mean that's what
that's what they want to say right but
it's led by Crown Prince Bonsall here
who murders people and we know he
murders people and and that Jared
Kushner has a father-in-law I don't know
if you know this his name is Donald
Trump he actually ran and became
president of the United States yeah and
actually that guy wildly destroys the
United States defended Saudi Crown
Prince bone saw about the murder
defended him these [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] so when people come at me for this
I was like
you [ __ ] idiots like the people that
come after me for this I'm like listen
again I'm not saying Hunter Biden is
pure and is an angel but what I am
saying is that if you're going to come
after Hunter Biden for his laptop and
all the you know things that he's done
through his life you should probably
follow that same energy and direct it
toward Jared Kushner Donald Trump Jr
Ivanka Trump Eric Trump these are people
who defrauded a child's Foundation right
a Children's Foundation they they stole
money they defrauded they are bad people
Lara Trump Eric Trump's wife misdirected
funds intentionally away from a [ __ ]
dog shelter uh Foundation like these are
the people they're literally stealing
from children and they're stealing from
pets like these are the people that you
want deciding the the policies and laws
in this country these are the people
that you trust to say they are
hard-working Americans no they're not
they're just game artists they're
grifters they will take and take and
take until you have nothing left and
when you don't have anything left
they're going to take everything they're
just going to take even more right so
they'll they'll make you you know
refinance your house and take out
another mortgage they'll keep asking you
to donate again recurring month and
month and month and month after again to
say hey we need to keep this fight
against the big lie because we need to
fight against Democrats and the
Socialist regime of of uh Joe Biden but
then they won't you know they won't use
that same energy to then look at
themselves and say oh actually these
guys are pretty bad at themselves like
they're taking money they're sex
trafficking they're they're uh they're
embezzling they're they're using a
political office for for their own gain
and profit like
across the board if someone on a
Democrat independent or Republican side
is doing something illegal
then they should all be handled they
should all they should all be you know
arrested convicted charged whatever they
should all be brought with the same
energy so you hate you hate Hunter Biden
well [ __ ] whatever I don't really care
but if you're gonna hate him for that
then you should also hate
Jared Kushner Ivanka Trump Eric Trump
Donald Trump Jr there's a lot of people
with the same last name in that family
that are doing a lot of shady [ __ ] and
there's one person on the other side
yeah he's a [ __ ] up and he did some
stuff and whatever
but if you're going to come and hunt or
bite and then you should probably follow
the same type of energy toward these
other people and let me tell you they
are [ __ ] you know they're deplorables
in a basket right like that's what they
are and a whole family if there are more
than one person in a family that's
causing some real issues more than two
people you've got a whole You've Got a
handful of people you could group them
up and just take them with
it's it's it well here's here's what
I'll tell you one thing that's not
happening the cognitive dissonance is
just like [ __ ] well yeah well
absolutely that's intentional it's will
for ignorance um it's Q Anon you know I
said yesterday it's a q Anon World we're
just living in it so
here's the one thing I'll tell you that
there's not
there's not like
um lines and lines of Democrats lining
up to take to pay two thousand dollars
to take pictures with Hunter Biden yeah
have you noticed this there's not people
out there they're like Hunter Biden's
good and they're holding up signs and
they're going to rallies we're Hunter
Biden speaking they're going to
fundraisers and giving thousands and
tens of thousands of millions of dollars
we're 100 binding speaking that Hunter
Biden doesn't show up at at Democratic
events and speak and act like he's in
politics Donald Trump Jr does Donald
Trump Jr doesn't Donald Trump Jr tried
to overthrow the election of the United
States he tried to take away your vote
he thought he would text the chief of
staff this isn't like he's texting his
buddy down the street like oh I don't
like Joe Budden Joe Biden shouldn't be
no he was texting the chief of staff hey
we've already lost this which is
probably the most significant part to me
yeah we've already lost this race but
there's a way we can steal it and it's
really [ __ ] Rich it's really [ __ ]
Rich of these people saying that Donald
Trump didn't lose and here is Donald
Trump Jr before they even call the race
for Joe Biden yeah texting the chief of
staff who's standing next to that the
president United States which is his
father and the reason why he's texting
Mark Meadows because he can't get a hold
of his father right right right his
father's probably got his number blocked
yeah but I feel like it's one of the
scenarios where it's like it's Donald
Trump Jr Mark Meadows and and Donald
Trump and in the room you've got uh uh
you've got Donald Trump Jr who's like
kind of looking like oh so like they're
in the same they're in the same room
they're like within six feet apart
because you know not social distancing
but they are six feet apart from each
other with Mark Meadows in the middle
and Don Don Jr is kind of like looking
like he's like texting he's like you
know you hear you hear Donald Trump's
phone go Bing
Bing and he's like answer the phone and
so then he's like so then he like texts
Mark Meadows and Mark Meadows opens the
phone it's like oh [ __ ] you know again
and then he goes your son Don says and
then he's like don't know him like
that's what I feel like it's one of
those things like you're sitting at a
dinner table right and one of the kids
and the parents are mad at each other
yeah you know like tell Mom tell Mom to
pass the mashed potatoes tell Dad and
they're like there's like Dad says mom
says it's like well if I could hear your
father then I would say tell him you
know but I also want to point out uh
Lisa over here said uh Gabe left out
melanoma she's Shady her AF herself now
for people who don't know who melanomas
that's Melania Trump
um but yeah for context yes she's
another one who you know through her own
grifter
nfts uh her her tea for charity uh scam
where she was like taking money and then
people like this charity doesn't even
exist you know speaking of corruption
when we're spring you know grifters and
Corruption do you really think he took
all the top secret stuff and all this
[ __ ] out of the White House for himself
he took it to sell it don't you think oh
yeah I mean like if you look at all the
photos he takes with different people
that visit like when Kyle Rittenhouse or
whoever came he does his little dumb
[ __ ] thumbs up thing right but if you
look at that then you see the stuff in
the background right him with uh Kim
Jong-un like you know he's got it he has
to stand in front of that picture right
exactly it's like that is my most
favorite picture ever is when I shook
hands with a murderous dictator who
[ __ ] commits genocide on his own
people like does he not even [ __ ]
understand like the the imagery of that
of a former president United States
standing with a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
murderer giving a thumbs up with the
with the [ __ ] a genocidal dictator
behind him that's like when he shook his
hand and he just like threw out his hand
and shook it and everyone's like no what
are you doing right
speaking of the documents that's another
video that's coming out oh okay
um we got an update on that then yeah
yeah that's uh that that's another one
coming out uh it turns out there's an
investigation now where the FBI has you
know uh received those documents from
the National Archives and they're now
going through those yeah I think they
even have a grand jury it sounds like
that there are something is that is that
right is there a grand jury that's mean
or I don't know there's so many grand
juries at this point you know everyone's
so concerned about whether Donald
Trump's going to pay a price or any of
these politicians are going to pay Price
look if the Department of Justice can
bring federal charges against a
politician whether it be a senator a
member of Congress a state official a
lieutenant governor of New York they
will [ __ ] do that they want that
notch on their goddamn belt I don't know
what people don't understand like that
like they want that notch in their belt
they don't care if it's Republican or
Democrat they don't give a [ __ ] they're
going to get that Notch that's what they
want because that advances them up
through the system exactly yeah yeah
right I took this person down or
whatever you know like yeah they want to
be attorney general someday you know
right exactly yeah so yeah it's uh just
be on the lookout that's another video
probably coming later this week
um so you know there's a there's
definitely you know a couple couple down
junior got a mark some content coming
yeah there's some content comments you
know that's good that's good hey you're
gonna stick around I think uh uh Dr
Rachel bittickoffer is going to join us
here soon you're gonna stick around for
that or you gotta you gotta I gotta I
gotta jump in oh you gotta jump in a
little bit let's let's do I think there
was one more story that I wanted to ask
you about yeah why I got you here for a
few for a few seconds
maybe it was the um oh crackle Cracker
Barrel is trending oh yeah I know what
it was it was Jesus Christ is Lord
that's what it was Jesus Christ the lord
is trending I'm not kidding I don't know
why I guess it's because oh because
Easter I guess so yeah yeah I've got an
Easter video coming up do you really
okay good well maybe it's too maybe too
late then Jesus Christ as Lord is
trending
um this is one of the best uh things
I've seen in this uh says Joe Biden
bring versus Donald Trump praying yeah
yeah well you know when you when you got
a bunch of pedocons when you got the
party who wants to marry children
um this is what happens this is what
happens when the grand old pedicons yeah
Jesus Christ is Lord uh
the hypocrisy of the
of the GOP towards Christianity did you
see did you see the uh they're passing a
trans Bill and speak speaking of
Christian people and christian-like
people
um the Tennessee holler has us let's see
if I can pull it up
um the uh the legislator in Tennessee of
course their despicable piece of [ __ ]
all Republicans you know I mean you know
if they if they couldn't double you know
that they're like Hey listen we're
already gonna try and lower the age of
uh of marriage which has now been
updated to be 18 right well I mean they
got caught you know one like married
children we'll see what happens when it
gets well other states are not not
updating their bills they're going
forward with their bills uh to marry
children uh let's see if I can find um
um anyways there's there's some good
video out there on the Tennessee holler
of children oh here here we go I think
this is it
um uh wanting to uh they're sexualizing
kids gender
um in of course the state Tennessee
let's see let's let's do this here
sorry a letter that I really think
everybody
should read
and what he pointed to
first of all was that there are over 70
000 people playing in sports in their
state
and they had identified exactly four
transgender youth who were playing
in exactly one who was playing in
women's sports so they give you context
the Utah legislator passed the
anti-trans sports bill as well
sexualizing the gender of children and
um and Tennessee is trying to do the
same thing this Democrat here at Jeff
Yarborough is trying to make sure people
understand why the the governor of the
state of Utah vetoed that bill because
it only affected one just one child
yeah just one one child in the sport
that they didn't want him to play in and
that's why the the governor Utah uh veto
that bill but you know the the the
pedocons the Republican kid diddlers in
Utah they said nope we're gonna
sexualize your kids gender whether you
like it or not and they overturned his
veto and just for people who know it
four out of 70 000 athletes is point
zero zero five percent right that is the
representation of the threat that they
that they feel so hardened and inflicted
by and that they project onto their
children here's the thing I guarantee
those kids don't give a [ __ ] those kids
are there to play the sport and do what
they love they don't care about how
their parents feel it's the same reason
that those mothers in Virginia said well
my kid comes home and they feel guilty
because they're white and their teacher
makes them feel really bad and ashamed
for the the past transgressions of this
country no the kid doesn't the kid
doesn't even know that the kid is
learning and doesn't inherently feel
like oh I'm white I'm the bad guy and
then go complain to their parents
it's complete [ __ ] it's the parents
feeling guilty for themselves and then
saying well others feel the same way
that I do and when I was at wine club or
I was at my book club or I was on my HOA
meeting these other mothers felt the
same way no the kids don't feel that way
you mothers feel guilty for whatever
privilege you have and whatever you've
taken advantage of and whatever uh oh
look at me look at me I'm the actual
victim kind desire and Limelight you
want it is not the children the kids
don't care and the only reason people
are complaining is because the adults
are the ones who are you know whether
they're trying to live vicariously
through their children uh or whatever or
they have their own projection or
beliefs or they feel insecure about
themselves and really wish that they
were comfortable in their own body and
and feel envious of people who actually
had the bravery and courage to do that
they themselves are the ones that are
projecting this this fear onto their
children and using their children as the
excuse for why they need to pass this
legislation but it's complete [ __ ]
right again 4 out of 70 000 kids seventy
thousand athletes in school is point
zero zero five percent no one is coming
after your sport no one is coming after
your place and how you rank you know if
anything like your your if you really
feel threatened then make you know take
it seriously train maybe you should feel
threatened by the Republicans who are
coming out right children I mean they
want to take your consent away from you
about your children they want to listen
to me when I say this they want to marry
your children and they want to take your
consent away from you about your
children think about that for a second
not only do they want to marry your
little girls they want to take your
consent away from you of what you
dictate about your children and how you
raise them a perfect example what you're
talking about though is at the Trump
rally over the weekend and I forget
exactly who released it I believe it was
like on Trader TV like Newsmax there's a
couple parents standing with some kids
like yeah we're so excited to be here at
the Trump rally at the Nazi rally how
how Trump Hal Trump and then and then
the reporter asked the little kid like
what uh are you excited to be here he's
like yeah he's like what what's the most
exciting part about being here it's like
we get to see Joe Biden and they're like
no Trump Trump trump and it's so [ __ ]
hilarious because they told these kids
that they're gonna go see the president
you're gonna go see the president you're
gonna go see the president you're gonna
go see the president son son are you
excited about seeing the president he's
like yeah the president's Joe Biden even
the [ __ ] kid knows that the president
is Joe Biden for crying out loud and it
just it it [ __ ] doesn't make any
sense the kids don't give a [ __ ] the
kids don't give a [ __ ] if boys and girls
are playing soccer together they don't
care if one person this person they
don't give a [ __ ]
bigotry and racism is taught it's taught
to a child it's taught to them just just
like some of this other Fascism and
stuff
um let's finish watching this video and
then we're going to go to a quick break
and I think Rachel Dr Rachel bittagov is
going to join us after this uh let's
watch this rest of this video
and I don't think there's any reason to
think that the numbers here in Tennessee
are all that different but we're now
just today this is our second piece of
legislation today Jesus Christ deal with
this
but I'm gonna stop here because
um this is the second piece of
legislation he's saying they did today
so Republicans are more focused on a few
children
um that identify as a certain gender
they don't care about children who are
under the poverty line they don't that's
right they don't care about Hunger they
don't care about feeding kids they don't
care about [ __ ] educating them they
don't give a [ __ ] they only care about
sexualizing your kids gender and take
their this is the thing with this trans
thing it's the same stupid [ __ ] that
they're doing with the marriage law
they're acting like it's a gay they hate
gays right they hate on gays we're gonna
hate us some gays with this gays
shouldn't get married that's the guys so
their base gets all riled up that this
is an anti-gay bill and it's good the
gays can't get married and all the while
they're selling it as an anti-gay Bill
they're they're wanting to marry
children here with this trans this
anti-tran [ __ ] they're doing the same
thing but what they're trying to do is
take your consent away from you for your
children
the fact that you know the the kind of
the final thing I'll say here is what it
reminds me of is the fact that he said
that this is the second one done in the
same day makes me feel like it's the
same approach that pharmaceutical
companies do when they have a patent on
a drug right after you know 17 or 20
years or whatever the patent rolls over
and then they say hey in order for us to
hold on to this patent and not just lose
it to generic manufacturers is we need
to modify something ever so slightly so
that we can come across and say there's
a whole new makeup of this thing and
it's completely different which is
typically not the case it's the same
thing slightly altered same effect so
when I look at this and I'm like oh
they're just making the same bills
modifying ever so slightly with the goal
that if one passes the other one gets
tossed out or if one doesn't pass and
they say well we got these other three
that are in the queue and they'll do the
same thing we want in whatever regard or
however extreme or whatever it is
because again we said it before is
before you know oh you know same-sex
marriage that is disgusting right the
sanctity of the marriage is totally
totally uh just just ruined because a
man wants a married man or a woman wants
to wear a woman or whatever it is and
now they said you know well now that's
more commonplace people accept that yeah
we don't really agree with it but the
majority of the country agrees that yes
that is fine that is okay we have no
problem and now they say well you know
what that's not extreme enough we have
to keep pushing further and further to a
point that is vile disgusting and just
outright gross and that's what we see
right now where they're saying well
trans people shouldn't have rights or
they shouldn't get married it shouldn't
do this and we're going to go into
bathrooms and we're going to make sure
that you are the gender that you say you
are you know it's like oh yeah they want
you to pull down your pants in a
bathroom so they can see your genitalia
that's how weird these [ __ ] are
that's how [ __ ] weird they are they
grow in the bathroom and they're [ __ ]
focused not on taking a [ __ ] or taking a
piss they're [ __ ] focused on someone
else's what the hell is in their pants
right they are [ __ ] weirdos that's
[ __ ] weirdos when they're what you
know I and I okay the final thing I'll
say this is you know during covid they
were like oh the whole like show us your
paper show us your papers it's the
vaccine card thing like it's like the
Gestapo asking for the papers no no no
what actually is like show me the papers
that's right is when somebody says Hey
show me your birth certificate show me
what you were born as truly prove that
you are right right show me what you are
who you are so that I can I can verify
that you should actually be here or that
you should have these rights that's the
true Gestapo people that is true fascism
when somebody is forcing you to prove to
them that you are who you are right oh
show me the birth certificate because I
want to see what gender you were born
female then you're a female you
shouldn't be here you're born male
you're male you shouldn't be here if
you're anything else then you don't have
the rights you don't have the same
access you aren't given any sort of just
uh well Gabe if you're a woman or a Gabe
if you're a woman you're in Oklahoma
you're about to be a felon if you
receive a certain medical procedure
right too and and let me tell you
something I said this earlier in the
episode
um uh in the announcements this is the
hill they want to die on folks and we
should go up on that hill and we should
we should fight them we should fight the
good things is a good example you should
fight this good fight on the hill we can
win this fight if you don't think we can
win the fight against against them
taking consent away from you from your
kids and then marrying them and wanting
to sexualize your gender and weird ass
bathroom genitalia stuff you don't think
we can win that fight taking away
women's absolute Liberty where they're
felons if they are a fi if they receive
a certain medical procedure in Oklahoma
you don't think we can win that fight
get the [ __ ] out of here stop that
cancel student debt [ __ ] let's let's
fight this fight we can win this fight
all day every day and then when we win
that fight we can cancel all the [ __ ]
student debt you want let's do that
let's do that all right let everyone
stick around Gabe thanks for joining us
dirty sanchez is uh his new nickname
everybody so go go tweet him as dirty
and don't Google it till after the show
and again don't go to Google Images you
won't get a picture of Gabe you'll get a
picture of a lot of well maybe you get a
picture game but you'll get a lot of
other videos I am not anywhere okay we
never ever want to do in your own home
but if you do it I'm sure a republican
will want to show up and do it for you
that's right that's right stick around
everybody we will be right back with Dr
Rachel bittigover stick around we'll be
right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we have
special arrival
[Music]
my favorite political strategies
in this country because she wants to go
on that hill and she wants to fight that
fight
and she wants to take the fight straight
to these pedocon Republican kid dealers
Rachel how are you
that last 10 minutes is a it
encapsulates why I can't just sit here
two hours a day and listen to you go
Tony because I get so engaged and I'm
like back in the backstage and I'm like
damn and like I just you know I can't do
it so you want a box I mean you know
some of these stories this morning like
uh for instance the shooting in the
subway car you know they're going to try
to use this tonight Tucker Carlson on
the news is going to be saying a bunch
of racist ass [ __ ] he's gonna be saying
a bunch of stuff about how there should
be more guns in that subway car and all
kinds of garbage all kinds of [ __ ]
garbage that that the story about the
lieutenant governor of the New York
um that that story is going to be turned
around on Fox News Tucker Carlson is
going to be yapping and telling lies and
[ __ ] probably pushing Russian
propaganda against that somehow it's
probably going to be Hunter Biden's
laptop I'm sure
um but I mean we can win all these
fights we can win all these battles we
can win all this messaging but they
truly do
want to die on the hill of this
pedophile Bill stuff yeah but Tony it's
so critical like you have such an
inherent talent to messaging and uh
almost like you'll say things all the
time that I want to yell bit a call for
Approved right because you get it it
isn't you don't need to argue down in
the micro part of this you want to keep
it about this they want to control what
how you raise your kids right that's the
heart of the message that's what book
burning is or Banning is about these
trans bills all of the [ __ ] that they're
doing we should be structuring it as
they are coming to indoctrinate your
children they want to turn your kids
against you kids you're absolutely right
kids don't give a [ __ ] right they don't
give a [ __ ] the kids don't give a [ __ ]
about the little girl or a boy on their
soccer team that may not have the you
know a genitalia that's traditionally
goes with a gender at least in their
household right so you know it's all all
coming from parents it's all really
frankly it's grooming right you're
grooming children into hatred and uh
fear of the other but it really is about
this they know they've lost the culture
war that ship sailed right we may wage
they may wage cultural issues as wedge
issues against us but the end of the
[ __ ] day they've gotten their asses
handed to them by culture right culture
is that ship has sailed in at least in
terms of like Democrat Democratic
management and so now what they're
looking for is undemocratic options
right how can they real how can they
protect their little snowflake children
from being exposed to people with
dangerous [ __ ] ideas well they
control the ideas if they control
education they control the political
system they can impose their cultural
imperatives on us and you know what
people may not know is that that's
predominantly what Hitler was concerned
about was culture right it wasn't just
the stuff with the Jews which is a major
component it was also other things and
one of these things was this idea that
the Roaring Twenties of Germany you know
we think about the Roaring Chinese here
but that stuff was Global right Germany
was a fresh democracy it's really a
fresh country only a
um organized itself into into you know
the Germany we think of now uh in the
1800s right and so when um the Weimer
Republic was kicking it through the 20s
and and even with the crises and the
inflation there's still modernization
occurring and especially in Berlin the
city's you know major Metropolitan
Metropolis area and Hitler was concerned
about the change in culture which was
moving away from a patriarchal rigid
nationalist white male Christian you
know system and they had just
enfranchised women in Germany too in
that election Maybe a couple elections
before so we're really looking at a
party that has lost the culture war and
we can kick their ass on it if we wanted
to if we did it right
I I think you're right because I I don't
understand like
everyone's like oh I I gas prices
inflation I'm like wait a second so
you're telling me you want the people
who want to marry little children
in charge of your gas prices in charge
of the inflation that's who you want in
charge of that stuff you want the people
who want to marry little kids who are
sexualizing kids gender who are only
focused on passing bills about
sexualizing kids gender marrying little
children you think those are the people
who are concerned about inflation or gas
prices you think those are the people
give me a [ __ ] break they don't care
two shits about gas prices about
inflation they don't care who they got
to blame it on all they care about is
their fascist ideas and making sure that
they indoctrinate their fascist ideas
into our culture because you're right
they've lost this culture where they
know they have that's why they're doing
this alternative marriage thing that's
literally what these bills are is we
lost a culture war on on marriage
certificates right that's their idea we
lost the war on marriage certificates
and now the sanctity of marriage is gone
so now we need to bring the sanctity of
marriage back and have our own special
little carved out thing for us snowflake
people who can't handle that that which
I has nothing to do with them two people
of the same gender get married that they
they have their own marriage license but
secretly they want to marry little kids
like like it's really [ __ ] weird and
you can't believe that people can't
can't get their heads around that that's
where the wind is like that's where it
is have you seen that that Tennessee
Republican I think he's a state
legislature who did literally marry a
little kid yes yes a very wild bride
right right right well yeah you know
obviously well I mean you have you have
a staffer from the RNC who was charged
and had child porn yeah and and
Democrats are the ones who are who it's
so hilarious
that Republican senators were accusing
while katanji Brown Jackson was putting
pedophiles and child pornographers in
prison while she was imprisoning them
Republican staffers at the RNC were
looking up child born and distributing
child born like literally they and they
were like oh Judge Brown Jackson bad
because she sent child pornographers to
prison like what are you [ __ ] yeah
like she sentenced them to a federal
prison she didn't like let them off she
sentenced them to prison Republican
entire Republicans elect them and
Democrats send them to jail and and
here's another like great analogy so
like a fantastic that's fantastic that's
fantastic
Republicans elect child pornographers
Democrats sending the deal that's
fantastic I mean that's the message
right and I said they don't get bogged
down in the in the yeah well actually
her sentence saying is not much
different than anybody no just [ __ ]
say that dude they tried to send one to
the U.S Senate 90 of Republicans voted
for Roy Moore dude he was a [ __ ]
serial child predator okay and then like
this Tennessee dude all right I I I I
was just I don't have like perfect
information so I'm gonna speculate a
little the young lady that he was
married to in his Instagram picture with
two children apparently they hooked up
when she was on his staff and you know
at least conjecturized under the age of
18. that happened to Democrats in
Virginia a few years back this dude and
he ended up making a political comeback
because you know now there's no rules
and that's the post-trump era but at
that time period he did the same thing
at an affair with the staffer who was
underage and he married or knocked her
up and married her so you know he did
the right thing Democrats get the [ __ ]
out and they kicked oh dude you know
that's the difference between these two
parties you really want your 16 year old
little girls featured in the hands of
the modern GOP
no the hell to the I don't wanna I don't
want them to control anything to be
honest like if that's your focus if you
can't handle that someone else in the
bathroom with you without focusing on
their genitalia I don't want you in
charge of anything really that's a
[ __ ] weird question show me show the
gops show me your panties law right yeah
that's right that's right well I mean
they definitely they definitely would
love to every every GOP or who is
elected it seems like every Republican
would love to stand at a bathroom door
and to inspect everyone's genitalia that
walk in that door I mean I I I'm
beginning to think that's what it is
Tony I want to be clear when they pulled
out my pants they're gonna see the
biggest [ __ ] hairiest swinging
balls anyone has ever seen
oh well you definitely you definitely do
have uh and some political uh balls on
you if you can say that because you you
really like to go at these people with
this fight and you know today inflation
is is trending
um yesterday the White House tried to do
the Putin price hike they tried to Brand
it as that
um obviously obviously inflation and I
said this morning I'm like look if you
really want a good argument when
someone's trying to come at you with
inflation just say would you rather have
a recession like do you remember 2008
would you rather have a recession the
reason why we have a lot of is inflation
is because the economy is heating up the
economy it's a biting boom I mean it's
really what is happening right now the
other the other component of some of
this inflation is Corporate inflation
where they're actually gouging the [ __ ]
out of us like with with the oil
companies crude is dropping and gas
prices are staying up so that isn't that
isn't uh the fault of Joe Biden there's
no gasoline I know and like I said you
have you cannot you we know what they're
gonna [ __ ] do like the first time
that I heard an economist on CNN or
MSNBC mentioned the word inflation was
early fall of last year okay and as soon
as I heard it I was like oh [ __ ]
inflation's coming they're gonna Jimmy
Carter Buy in a hundred [ __ ] percent
and of course they it's so handy right
because you can do bide inflation right
bite inflation it's very nice right and
um you know there's nothing that we can
do because the media is going to talk
about inflation and make it turkey
inflation is going to be much more
important than Democratic like uh
governance in 2022 because of the
narrative right so we need to run into
inflation and this is where my Pivot and
attack strategy is so good right so you
know someone if they're going to attack
us on inflation you define things versus
abide and boom but then you pivot a new
attack and you blame inflation on them
because if we do that the electorate's
gonna hear they they know inflation's
bad right now the system is set up where
they're going to hear one message it's
the Democrats Falls Biden's fault okay
our job is to fill that vacuum be like
no it's [ __ ] Republicans fault it's
all their fault and at least that way
we're neutralizing this wedge that
they're planning to deploy against us
right well and that's the thing that
they do is they distract with things
like
um how that lies about inflation lies
about the economy so that way they can
pass laws to sexualize your kids as
gender and to marry them that's what
they're doing and to take away women's
Liberty have you heard about this law in
Oklahoma holy [ __ ] you know I haven't I
haven't heard the governor signed it
this morning they are they he signed a
law where uh it basically makes it
you're you're a felon
in the state of Oklahoma if you have a
uterus and you have a certain medical
procedure
um it is getting to the point to where
they're taking away every woman's
Liberty and every person who has a
uterus is Liberty inside these states
and don't think it's not coming to your
state don't think they won't do it
I mean that's why I'm trying to get
Democrats to understand look we should
be running a red State versus Blue State
reality message right this is what
because if there are Michigan
Pennsylvania uh Wisconsin right
um let's see not yeah so there are three
states right now that are swing States
no four because New Hampshire that are
controlled by Republicans and we are not
making it clear to voters in those swing
States this is what you get two choices
in America now government by these
morons which is you know terrifying
or competent government that brought you
through the pandemic that you know
probably is the most successful economic
catastrophe we've ever been through as
the pandemic that's been handled
absolutely [ __ ] brilliantly when you
think about the entire [ __ ] economy
the entire [ __ ] thing shut down dude
for a long time and then it only
partially reopen and yet here we sit
here most of us have maintained our
homes because of the mortgage and rent
moratoriums the or because of enhanced
unemployment if it was up to the
Republican party all those people on
unemployment would have been living off
of a third of their [ __ ] salary
unless they're low-wage workers and we
would have seen this massive [ __ ]
foreclosure crisis we'd still be
murdered in the [ __ ] if we had let the
Republicans Hoover their way through
this [ __ ] pandemic and we need to
make it clear
well you know it Democrats also
delivered inflation protection and
Republicans have blocked it now
Democrats delivered through the child
tax credit inflation protection it was
Cash directly into the accounts of
Americans to hampered the [ __ ]
inflation that was coming and they knew
that was coming and then when they tried
to renew it with the big bird bill
that's what I call it the bill back
better bill but I caught the Big Bird
bill it's not the big bird Bill if they
if Republicans and and the conservatives
and the Senate would not have blocked
the bill back better act that that
inflation protection would have been
extended and Democrats would have
delivered that inflation too like and
I'm like look look number one they
people don't really understand where
that six hundred dollars came from and I
was proud of Biden even though it was
class you know not Trump remember when
Trump gave people a tax cut and then he
wrote everybody a letter or whatever
right so at least the Biden team made it
clear this [ __ ] came from the White
House right and that's good I'm glad
that they did that but at the end of the
day people don't really understand where
that money came from and they sure as
[ __ ] don't understand why it went away
right and our job is to tell them they
stole your three or six hundred dollars
a month and you know they're they want
to steal more from you because they have
proposed a massive tax hike on middle
and working Americans
well of course they I mean they want
that's who they want to tax because they
want to lower taxes for guys like I
don't know like Elon Musk you know like
that guy that guy he pays way too much
in Texas right like that guy he he can't
even afford to yeah I don't know buy
nine percent of Twitter you know it's
really sad yeah you want to have some
fun with Elon Musk if you ever [ __ ]
nail him down which of course you never
will but if you did if I ever did I'd be
like yeah so Elon why don't you live in
Texas dude right exactly yeah Freedom
[ __ ] love analysis
because even though he has to pay people
a better wage and you need all these
environmental standards [ __ ]
[ __ ] Elon Musk doesn't want to live in
Texas okay he doesn't want to live in a
place where personal and individual
liberty bodily autonomy is getting
rolled back where there's bigots okay
like he's still a technocrat and he
likes living in California because
Democrats control California and
therefore it's [ __ ] nice well I mean
and and there's there's good cause to
believe that why would a guy who claims
that he wants freedom and freedom of
speech to go to a state where they are
trying to strip that away from people
like they are actively the people in
charge are actively trying to make sure
that there's not Liberty in their state
and we are getting to a point to where I
call it the Cheeto Confederacy where we
have you know during the Civil War we
had the northern states and the southern
states and we're getting to a point
where we have the red States and the
blue States like you were saying and
it's almost like there's this this
Cheeto dust Confederacy right like um
and and they're only in the name of
trump and it and do you think because
I've said it for a while
I actually like in Missouri in the
Missouri Senate race and a few other the
Senate races
um like in Georgia with Herschel Walker
and some of these others uh Josh Mandel
in Ohio which is a big race I think
Democrats can actually win do you think
that having a trump trump-loving
candidate on the Republican side isn't
such a bad idea I mean you tell me
no I mean here's the thing it doesn't
[ __ ] matter right they're going to
run a system it's going to be a system
that disqualifies us okay and it doesn't
matter if it's Mandel or
um JD Vance or whoever the [ __ ] it is
right no matter how crazy this person is
like it it they can either be legit
crazy or just crazy enablers right and
they're gonna still have the same
electoral viability and the party is
fooling itself if it thinks not so like
it's looking at uh Todd Aiken in 2012
and I've covered this in my book and I
said look in in 2012 when Todd Aiken the
Republican nominee in the Missouri
Senate race running against clarecast
mccask goal for her first re-elect in
the presidential cycle when that
happened like our Civic culture had not
made this final Lurch the Trump like
level Lurch and you see in the voting
returns that Todd Aiken the Republican
lost some Republican voter support you
can see that what you don't see in
Alabama Senate a few years later with
Roy Moore the child molester you did see
in Missouri and and the reason why I
want to point out that do and didn't did
and didn't difference is the
polarization and Hyper partisanship that
kicked in on the Republican side hits
its apex after 2016 and it changes the
rules of the [ __ ] game the same guy
that got driven out of the Missouri
Governor's Mansion for a scandal is now
and he's gonna get elected and he's
going to get 90 of the vote from
Republican voters in Missouri go look at
the polling data and break it down by
party and that's what you're going to
see if if not better right and it's just
you know it's good that they're going to
be crazy nominees and it certainly helps
but I I you know I don't none of our
[ __ ] people are crazy okay none of
them except for like five and they were
they they impose that crazy on ever
everyone do you see what I'm saying
right exactly we have
we have the same damn thing so it
doesn't matter if it's Carrie lake or
somebody's not we're less knots less
fascist they all must be branded against
aggressively and that brand must be
defining the Republican party as a
threat this person is a republican this
party is a threat well and if you don't
believe that just look at how they have
cast out a Liz Cheney Adam kinsiger just
for defying Truth uh Mitt Romney is no
longer real I mean have you heard from
Mitt Romney lately I mean he was the
only he was the only one only dude in in
the on the Republican side only man who
stood and clapped for kbj when she was
confirmed and the rest of them
pathetically like a bunch of [ __ ]
crybabies walked out of the room and
really we made Mitt Romney into a hero
which he's not he's not a hero for
clapping but here's what we got to do if
you think that Mitt Romney and Liz Janie
and Adam kinzinger are going to be in
charge if Eric greitens is a senator
Universal Walker is a senator if Josh
Mandel or JD Vance if all these Trump
sycophants are are Governors and
Lieutenant Governors and secretaries the
state and their and their their Congress
people their their [ __ ] Senators you
think you think that Mitt Romney is
going to be in control of that party
absolutely not and if if you don't think
that this Trump Scourge is going to not
continue just because oh well it's just
Republicans no they they are fascists
they are Trump Republicans it is it is
American fascism which is fascism in a
manga hat yeah I mean to be clear there
are precisely two House Republicans that
you can say are not either coup
conspirators or couplot enablers okay
um and that's Adam kinsinger and Liz
Cheney the entire rest of the [ __ ]
house caucus or the Republican Party had
the ability the option whatever to join
the select to join this committee you
know they tanked the select committee on
purpose only two are willing to say to
the to the extent where they'd
sacrificed their own political careers
to do so if need be the uh big lie is a
big lie it's part of a conspiracy
against the government and it needs to
be dealt with right and so like in my
opinion if you're a republican that took
the vote not to certify the election in
the house you are no worse to me than
the multitude of other Republicans who
didn't take that vote but aren't saying
[ __ ] about the gop's conspiracy to
overfer the government okay like if
you're not willing to stand up for the
rule of law and put country over party
then you are a coup enabler and you
should be painted in the same [ __ ]
basket as a danger for democracy as
anybody else
well and I think that you know goes back
to the imagery of uh Darth Vader himself
Dick Cheney coming to the floor and in
solidarity with Nancy Pelosi on the
anniversary the one-year anniversary of
the Insurrection the violent
Insurrection when they were when they
were honoring the the police officers
that lost their lives and the only other
Republican standing there was his
daughter Liz Janie who's the only the
only sinning Congress person on the
Republican side who who who came to that
ceremony and and and and I think the
imagery of Dick Cheney standing next to
her is a sign that this party is divided
and we can draw those wedges like that's
the other thing that I [ __ ] hate
about about Democrats are really
pro-democracy messaging if you want
because it's not really Democrats
anymore there's only one party party
that's War democracy and really honestly
even if you're not for Liberal ideas and
you're kind of lost out in la la land
because you can't be a fascist you're
kind of lumped in with the Democrats now
because there's really only only one
party that's for democracy right and
that's right
that tent is that you just described
though Tony right I mean like that's a
big [ __ ] tent which is why
instead of focusing on issues that that
people that causes division or parts of
that coalition to be either mad because
it's not their thing right so within the
base you get that resource competition
attention competition issue or on the
other side this this hesitant part of
the Coalition which is you know as as
important as the other components is you
know when we think about those people
the worst thing to [ __ ] do like in
terms of getting them to stick with us
and to show up is to like trigger latent
partisanship in them right so we do want
to keep it thematic and we want to make
it clear there is no choice other than
democracy and autocracy one party is for
democracy the other party is cryptocracy
right right well and you know there's no
better image of drawing wedges through
these Republicans than a a republican
debate that was in Ohio when Josh Mandel
lost his [ __ ] on another Republican and
they they were gonna fight each other
hey all kinds of dumb [ __ ] and it's and
these are the wedges that we have to
draw we have to let them fight each
other because that's what they've always
done to us they're always on the same
[ __ ] team right no matter what no
matter how bad it is no matter how bad
it may be for them they are always on
the same [ __ ] team they always always
always stand behind the [ __ ] rapists
behind the child pornographers behind
the pedophiles they stand right behind
them and they support them like Rory
Moore and the other the other this other
guy in Tennessee uh for instance the
rapist of Donald Trump himself they
stand behind them because they're on the
same team because they know they know
we're gonna fight about about is the
minimum wage does it need to be 15 or
18. that need to be 20. they know we're
gonna have this huge large fight and
we're gonna be able to draw wedges
between us on those issues our cancel
student debt or whatever that issue is
but they know they can draw those wedges
we can do the same thing and I think
that's always been our argument is that
we can do the things that they've always
done to us and we can be successful and
what it does is it puts pro-democracy
first not and it gives us the
opportunity to do those issues to pass
those bills to talk about the line items
because all those line items that you
want and all that fancy stuff that you
want to do in government it's not going
to happen if they take over it's not
yeah and it's not going to happen if we
waste another election season touting
bipartisanship right and collaboration
because what that we know that message
was ineffective in 2020 we know
Democrats did it 10 times or whatever
more than their Republican counterparts
who cleaned up all those swing races in
one right and here's why because it
[ __ ] normalizes the Republican Party
dude like this is not a normal moment
and if we treat it like one we're sure
to lose that's the surest path to
destruction in the midterm is to not
have the electorate woken to this moment
and you know this bipartisan [ __ ] it's
the exact it does nothing so it'd be one
thing if it lifted some Swing Vote to
vote for you well you're touting
bipartisanship and that same voter pull
the swing buckets getting hit with
Democrats are all socialists who wanted
to fund the police so good [ __ ] Luck
winning that and number two if we don't
hit them really really hard on you know
their extremism their radical extremism
I mean those words hardly ever showed up
in our ads in 2020 and they've used them
over and over even though we only have
five crazy people in our whole Coalition
right we have to Define them as
extremists as radicals and if we're
walking around touting at how we're
going to reach across the aisle and work
with them that's kind of counter [ __ ]
productive
yeah and you know what I say [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them I I don't want to work with a
bunch of faces I don't want to work with
a bunch of pedocons who want to take my
consent away from me want to take my
Liberty away who want to marry my
children okay but but like you can okay
you could argue theoretically right that
those could be red meat issues for right
no here's the thing like you got you
want to keep it really large large theme
right and you know like I I say 30 000
did I say thirty thousand forty Thousand
Foot Right like you want to keep this
broad yeah so like let me put it this
way like when we're all right
um when you're talking about the
um you know these issues we have to make
them sound
the government is coming in like you
know they're using the government to
come after your children they're using
the government to come after your
pocketbook whatever right we want to
make sure the villain is is them and not
defense of the material they want to ban
defense of the group that they want to
demand you know even pointing out how
few people there are technically we're
still engaging the issue where they want
us to be and where we need to be pulling
back in in every topic is on this big
thematic message fear the Republican
Party
I I think you're right I think you're
right I love talking politics with you
by the way did you know that did you
know that and and all the audience here
loves you they they love Dr Rachel
bittickoffer and I love them and I love
you Tony it's it's always so much fun
for me to come to the show well um come
back next week I'm sure there'll be just
a hundred other things that these
fascists will do between now and then
that would just be absolutely despicable
and vile and I'm sure that we'll have
plenty to talk about they always give us
uh just a ton of content to to do here
on the Tony Michaels podcast Rachel
thank you very much for joining us I
appreciate it as always we will see you
soon and everyone stick around uh we
will be right back after these messages
foreign
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with Biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face well now you
don't have to be introducing the droop
with our patented droop technology every
mask is uniquely molded to not fit your
face just send us a selfie and we'll
have one of our droopers mold the mask
for you elastic free thanks to the truth
I don't even need to pull my mask down
anymore it just sags that way the droop
lets you customize from a selection of
pre-war masks lipstick stains included
make sure to order your droop today
droop be the spread you want to see in
the world
catch Tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
Roundup at twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels we're back to the king of
Brilliance this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around after the break Dr
Rachel bittickoffer
giving you the lowdown on how to message
these [ __ ] how to fight fascism
with messaging I think that's how we win
this thing I think that's how we win I
think that's how we win the race that
we're gonna come upon in 2022 but not
just then uh past that Democrats need to
figure out
how to win an election with messaging
and then do every one of them like that
not not like just this one like we need
to continue to do this right like I'm
gonna do this show two hours a day every
single weekday Monday through Friday on
YouTube Twitter twitch and now on the
mind is touch Facebook page every single
day two hours
every single weekday from now until the
midterms and then once the midterms are
over I'm going to continue to do it two
hours a day I'm not gonna let up on
these [ __ ] do you think they're gonna
let up on you they think that you think
they're gonna stop trying to take your
Liberty away
you think so well look look here
this is the uh let me let me um pull
this up here this is the the governor
of the state of uh Oklahoma here's the
story here here's the trend
Oklahoma governor signs bill to make
abortion illegal uh Governors Kevin
Stitt I don't know I think we should
change his name it I think it should be
[ __ ] right Kevin [ __ ] Kevin [ __ ] signs a
bill on Tuesday making it a felony to
perform an abortion
in the state of Oklahoma
this is
you get what they're trying to do here
right
they're trying to have a challenge
against Roe v Wade This is a total
violation of Roe v Wade
that it's a felony to perform an
abortion
in the state of Oklahoma
they're taking away they're taking away
your Liberty and it says that uh State
House of Representatives previously
passed a bill that punishes performing
an abortion except in the life of a
pregnant woman in medical emergencies
and up to 10 years in prisons and a
hundred thousand dollar fine the state
senate passed the bill last year and the
Governor of Oklahoma has signed it
has signed it they want to take your
Liberty away for having a life-saving
medical procedure don't let the [ __ ]
medical emergency [ __ ] confuse you do
not let that get in your way don't let
it get in your way because see this is
what the media does the media says
medical emergency well who gets to
decide that you don't think the governor
of the state of Oklahoma you don't think
the Republicans in Oklahoma you don't
think they're going to decide when it's
a medical emergency and when it's not
when do you think they're going to
decide that you have a medical emergency
when
I mean they won't let you have autonomy
over your body you think they're going
to have you have autonomy over your
medical emergency get the [ __ ] out of
here it doesn't say life-saving it just
says medical emergency they get to
Define it they'll Define it
they're taking your [ __ ] Liberty away
and all you men out there that listen to
me all you [ __ ] men out there that
listen to me if you're not completely
[ __ ] pissed off completely [ __ ]
pissed off that they're taking away your
wives your sisters your mothers your
daughters Liberty away from them you are
not doing this [ __ ] correctly
no [ __ ] group of men should be
telling women what and where to do with
their [ __ ] body
I guaran damned to you that there's not
one [ __ ] legislator in Oklahoma
that would what let a woman tell them
what to do with their [ __ ] body
because there's not one goddamn bill
that these [ __ ] are passing
trying to take Liberty away from white
men who are in power
don't doubt me
they're coming for you
you may not think you're like oh well
Tony I'm I'm a dude I'm a dude
I'm a dude it's no big deal I can't I
can't even have an abortion
they're coming for you
two they're not gonna stop you think
they're just gonna stop here you think
they're just gonna oh well we took we
took the liberty away from women in
Oklahoma so that's it we're done oh boy
we really cleaned house on that one good
thing we good thing we really worked
hard because we're done now we're not
gonna try anymore to take anyone else's
Liberty away from them
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
they are not going to stop
at women in Oklahoma's Liberty they're
not going to stop there
they're not gonna stop
at LGBT communities right to marry each
other they're not gonna [ __ ] stop
there they're not gonna stop at just
wanting to marry your children
they're not going to stop at just
wanting to sexualize your children's
gender they're not going to stop
at being obsessed with people's
genitalia in bathrooms
they're going to take your [ __ ]
Liberty away from you they're going to
take your consent away from you
don't think that they'll take your
consent they're wanting to take consent
away from parents from that have trans
kids you don't think they're gonna do
you don't think they're gonna take your
consent away from you with cisgender
kids they want to marry your [ __ ]
children
all under disguise the disguise of
discriminating against the LGBT
community
because you know what's a good
Republican bill without a little
discrimination in it
don't doubt me I'm telling you they are
coming for you
they are coming for you and your
children
and it will not stay they are not going
to stop
they are not going to stop talking about
it they're not going to stop airing lies
on Fox News they're not going to stop
propagating it on social media they're
gonna not they're not gonna stop trying
to discriminate and hate people they are
not going to stop
so why should we I think it's worth
fighting for every single person's
Liberty in this country is worth
fighting for even the fascists that's
right I think we should even fight for
the fascist Liberty because I actually
think that if they'd experience actual
Liberty
maybe they'll maybe they'll see the
light and decide that democracy is the
thing that delivers it to them
because that's ultimately the thing that
we want that we strive for in our
democracy and any democracy for that
matter but ours specifically is Liberty
there's a document it says life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
you want to live do you want Liberty do
you want to be free
and do you want the chance to live the
American dream
well that's it folks
they want to take it away from you
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating morons
and when they take Liberty away from
your neighbor just one of them just
[ __ ] one of your neighbors one of
your neighbor's children
they'll come after you
if they know oh man if they know they
can take your [ __ ] Liberty away that
easily strip it away from you oh man
there's a ton of people out there that
they'd love to take their Liberty
they can't wait to take their Liberty
away from them they hate those
[ __ ] rather they be a certain
race a certain religion a certain gender
a certain a certain sexual orientation
they [ __ ] love it oh man they love to
take their Liberty away
they can't wait
so much so that they're showing their
cards
with these Republican state bills
discriminating
against gay marriage all to disguise
their pedophilia these pedocon
Republican kid diddlers
trying to marry your children and it
ain't women trying to marry little boys
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
it's it's grown ass men trying to marry
little girls
that's what it is these sick [ __ ]
we have a big Coalition like Rachel
said
Doc's got it right we got a big
coalition
a huge coalition
I believe there's more pro-democracy
people in this country and have been for
a long time I believe that's why Joe
Biden won the election in 2020 not
because 81 million people voted for Joe
Biden because I don't believe 81 million
people voted for Joe Biden they voted
for democracy they voted against
trumpism it's a threat to democracy and
we must treat it as such and that's
where our Coalition lies that's where
our Coalition will win you want to win
the house you want to win the Senate do
you want to win state races do you want
to make sure your governor and your
lieutenant governor and your [ __ ]
Secretary of State and your attorney
general aren't passing laws to make it a
felony because you receive a medical
procedure that saves your life do you
want to make sure of that then you
better go [ __ ] vote and you better be
talking to every single [ __ ] person
you can about voting and who to vote for
and who to definitely vote the [ __ ]
against
because they're coming for you and
they're coming for your children they're
coming for their bodies they're coming
for their minds
and they won't stop
unless we stop them that's how we can we
do not have to put these people in power
we do not have to allow them to be in
power of anything we can stop them
that's the beauty of democracy that's
the beauty of the vote
that's the beauty of Liberty we have
that freedom we have that right and
don't let them trying to bang up our
voting rights stop you crawl over hot
lava to get to those poles crawl drag
drag your community members your church
members people that you know from school
from the grocery store drag them over
the hot lava
to make sure that democracy is saved
that's what we have to do and we can do
it with messaging folks they want to die
on the hill of pedophilia that's where
they want to die they want to go up on
the hill and fight and fight to marry
little children and to take away women's
Liberty to choose whether they get a
medical a life-saving medical procedure
or not
yep that's where we're at they want to
take away your bodily autonomy they want
to sexualize your kid's gender and they
want to [ __ ] marry your children
that's that's the hill they want to die
on
and I want to go fight them there so
let's do that every single weekday right
here on YouTube Twitter twitch we are
going to pound the microphone we are
yelling screen the messaging into this
microphone and you listen
and you go out and you pound the
messaging out there
and continue and continue and continue
we we cannot stop
and I won't every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific YouTube
Twitter twitch go follow us the Tony
Michaels podcast and now coming to you
from the Midas touch Facebook page
us pro-democracy people
guys we can do this
it's not out of the realm
I mean you should be fearful you should
be scared that they're gonna win and
that's why we have to fight so goddamn
hard
and the Fight Continues folks this
afternoon tomorrow tomorrow morning
tomorrow afternoon next week and the
month after that
but until tomorrow at noon Eastern 11
Central right here on YouTube Twitter
twitch and the Midas touch Facebook page
until then Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon